prend
lesotes voilà s'il te plaît hop coup ah
ouais je t'ai dis pour en avoir assez
faut avir de trop c'est la maxime du
jour ouais c'est ça tu
vois donc tu vois ça chante et ce n'est
plus quatre mais si mains aujourd'hui
qui sont à l'œuvre pour faire revenir et
flamber ces pleurottes vous êtes prêts
et
voilà ça sent bon ouais tu vois puis là
tu as tu as vraiment cette sensation de
marque qui se mélange au Sous-Bois du
champignon c'est un régal
ça la bchelle c'est la première que vous
faites avec Camille ex mais c'est pas la
première que vous allez manger vous en
AZ mangé ailleur non non non manger non
disons que j'ai eu l'occasion de manger
celle que Jean Bardet faisait et donc
Jean Bardet qui était deux étoiles au
Michelin à tour c'est lui qui a enlevé
le feuilleté dans la bchelle Jean bardé
l'a enlevé et nous on va le remettre et
nous on va le remettre
voilà François c'est Monsieur jamais
trop Camille c'est Madame parfaite qui a
poché les pommes de riz veau pour mieux
enlever les petites peau que l'on
apprécie peu sous la dent et les
découper alors les escalopes de ridau
alors elles sont prêtes et je les farine
légèrement en fait pour qu'elles puisse
dorer quand je vais les mettre à la
poêle avec du beurre voilà ça ça va
faire une petite une petite croûte très
fine sur le riz veau et ça va le rendre
légèrement croustillant un peu de crème
dans les champignons et tandis qu'on
laisse réduire on s'occupe des
rignons tu vois tu as vu comment ils
sont contents les rignons ça chante ça
danse et là il y a un vrai travail
d'équipe de sur la sur la
poile c'est plus rigolo que de que de
cuisiner tout seul il y a un petit peu
d'émulation il y a l'un qui a une idée
l'autre qui rebondit sur l'idée de
l'autre on enlève le beur de la première
cuisson et les rognons rejoignent les
champignons histoire que ça mijote
ensemble tu vois et ça chante maintenant
côté rideau côé rideau
voil la recette se termine à l'unisson
et avec de jolies feuilletés hommage au
vol vent qui agrémenta la recette
originale et Fouré d'un peu de
champignon et pour finir un plat moderne
qui mérite bien ce petit supplément
[Musique]
crostillant et ils sont parfaits les riz
de veau crousti ça croque et ben oui
c'est le finalement c'est assez léger je
m'attendais un plat plus roboratif et
finalement c'est délicieux ch première
belle grande réussite on est content on
est content la bchchelle un plat
finalement aussi léger que ce vol qui se
plie à toutes les fantaisies de la forme
aux saveurs du sucré au salé royalement
bon